the following contains images of graphic
violence viewer discretion is advised
May 15 2012 Fullerton City Council
meeting was the first after the public
saw previously concealed security
footage of Kelly Thomas getting beat to
death by police the footage was shown in
court as a part of a preliminary hearing
for corporal Jason Ellie and officer
Manuel Ramos and subsequently released
online to the public this has been hard
already watching the video last week
with that we want to hear what you have
to say residents and sympathizers waited
over 10 months for the footage to be
released so when they had a chance to
tell the city what they thought they
didn't hold back I walk out when the
judge said we're not control ourselves I
walked out
you know I'm not rude I'm pissed the
outrage in the room reflected a palpable
distress for city officials any word you
can describe to downplay what we were
saying Sisson le will stand trial for
involuntary manslaughter and excessive
force and Ramos for involuntary
manslaughter and second-degree murder
but they may not be the only officers
reprimanded Ron Thomas Kelly's father
pushed for the firing and arrest of
another officer involved
Joseph Wolfe after review of the
surveillance tape he brutally murdered
Kelly and the two huge elbows that he
delivered after the baton strike a you
see the big pool of blood form a crush
Kelly Faison
so this department could have in fact
arrested him before that they haven't
done that you still being paid so we're
demanding it things are changing in
Fullerton the mayor has already been
replaced and a recall of City Council
members linked to the police department
is in the works Ron Thomas has promised
to begin protesting in front of the
police department again these folks
don't want to cooperate we'll go start
our protesting in we'll be right back
out there yes trust that badge is really
really really hard to do Kelly Thomas
and there's after Kelly toys that is a
line all of the citizen action signals
one thing there will be an act to to the
Kelly Thomas story hopefully that second
act will involve local law enforcement
regaining the trust of its citizens but
when something this horrible is caught
on tape it's hard to forget Act one for
recent TV
I'm Paul Detroit